champion major the president and first  lady's dogs are members of the family  are still getting acclimated and  accustomed to their new surroundings and  new people and on monday the first  family's younger dog  major was surprised by an unfamiliar  person  and reacted in a way that resulted in a  minor injury to the individual  which was handled by the white house  medical unit with no further treatment  needed  it had been previously planned already  for the dogs to be cared for by family  friends in delaware during dr biden's  travels  to military bases this week she has a  three-day trip this week  and the dogs will return to the white  house soon